oh is that is that the key it's oh oh
look there's people hello
I learned something very cool well I
knew it but I was reminded in two
specific instances in the last 20
minutes in the break of the power of
smiling at people as I was going past
two people they smiled at me I smiled
back
I felt better I suspect they felt better
as well so you know top tip smile at
people it really works
yes it's cool Francis smile at us right
so it's always great to catch up
whenever I come to UK I try to catch up
with you
yeah on stage in front yeah so apologies
to those who wanted undivided mats as it
were this was me joining Mads at the
kind of last minute old Tuesday I think
it was so thank you very much - Mads for
inviting me up here so I get to do a
versioning talk tomorrow instead of a
CTR peak talk because I figured that
yeah there's only so much c-sharp 8 that
one conference can have it's like you
silly high-level but we've been pushing
it and at this conference we're
everything had to talks with will go
Wagner yesterday and now how many of you
were at those talks or at least one of
them okay maybe let's do it the other
way around
how many of you weren't so therefore
okay still a good number probably yeah
you shouldn't entirely skip the null
thing if it was like you were all here
for null you don't want to spending ten
minutes going over exactly the same
stuff right but now we will now we will
yeah
because to our thing enough yeah so
anyway do you think they know who we
actually introduce ourselves or yeah
yeah good okay I'm I'm Masterson I'm the
lead designer of c-sharp Microsoft and
I'm John skeet I'm a c-sharp fanboy
basically I'm star software engineer at
Google I work on the Google cloud
platform dotnet client libraries but the
reason I'm up here is because I'm a
c-sharp family basically good
so with that cleared away we have a we
have a lot of intro slides here no
actually that's it we have a we have
Visual Studio so what we're going to
talk about is mostly you know what's
coming in c-sharp a we're going to play
with the late
preview that came out last week well
some of it came out this week the the
framework parts and we just kind of play
with it I told Johnny - okay that he
comes up to my keyboard and types hello
what tends to have long as I watch him
doing it yeah when I come up and type in
preview builds I tend to end up fighting
compiler issues just entirely
accidentally I'm I have a massive corner
cases I mean how the hell me okay so so
we got to do that we're gonna go through
some of those features and then towards
the end we can talk about you know there
a some of the things that aren't in
preview bills yet that we still imagine
being in there and what's new what what
are we imagining for the for the further
out future of c-sharp Kudo shut tanker
to you let's go for it okay so a piece
of code here I have I have an array I'm
creating an array of people persons we
can see from me from the the type Harbor
type here and I want to just go through
and print them all out so I have a
little display method here the friends
the first name first letter of the
middle name and the last name so that is
totally basic stuff for each of our
person in people display it display the
person boom alright what happens well
deliberately didn't show yeah and we
haven't even shown the person type but
you know you can go and I guess some of
what's going on there Joe and skeet Oh
boom okay okay do we still have the
output so we can yeah it should still be
there yeah so it's apparently it's
allergic to you know it got me I'm fine
oh it's yeah it's just you yeah I like
this a compiler that owner what happened
that's let's go back here and see oh we
got a null reference exception why did
we get a null reference exception well
present that middle name don't get
returned now oh oh someone we need
have a middle name so if we if we exit
out of the debugger here and actually
look at that array
yeah sure enough you're the only one in
here who has a middle name
I like being special yes well probably
more people have middle names but I
didn't know their middle names but no
reference exception it feels like there
is a feature for that yes the new
version of the app for that so how could
we have avoided this you know how could
we have avoid shipping this app to a
million people and then and then it
crashed you know that's that's when all
the reference types are out okay so the
idea being that we can like we can there
are things that you can't express today
in c-sharp that maybe we can let you
express mm-hm such as you know hey this
thing's supposed to be null or not right
we can't say two days so we have to sort
of guess right should I be checking for
knowledge or be handling know especially
or use alternative approaches so in no
time
that I'll probably mention notice I'm a
bunch it's my dotnet date and time
library and I sort of prepped for
nullable reference types before they
were even on the horizon by I have an
attribute on every public method that
returns a reference type saying whether
or not it will return null and I
actually have a test that makes sure
that every public method has either that
either can be no or should not be null
and I'm trying to currently work out
with nullable reference sites should I
get rid of those tests or should I
assume that if I've just written one
thing it's kind of okay and that's what
I meant you know one thing about having
to put attributes in it makes you really
really explicit and as matt said
yesterday there was an option of
considering having this is an honorable
string this is a nullable string this is
a no one's decided string there's
something to be said for always being
explicit yeah I fully believe that
classes should be sealed by default
rather than unsealed by default but I'd
also have been fine with there being no
default and saying you have to say I
want to seal I
to unseal so always think about you not
just can i express intention but am i
forced to expression intention yes so so
the challenge here is that the world is
full of code it's full of use of
reference types and some of them are
supposed to be null and some are not
should we make you rewrite all of that
code to be explicit about your
intentions in both directions or should
we just make you rewrite and we we opted
for only making you rewrite half of that
code week and so essentially the idea is
that we can now and and I'm now going to
go and do it
we can now turn so it's a feature that
you have to turn on and then it's going
to essentially up the level of scrutiny
of your code as sort of typically the
first way you'll meet this feature on an
existing code is you turn it on and it's
going to start complaining about things
in your source code and it's gonna
complain nicely let's listen in one way
you can turn it on if you just want to
try it on a little bit of your code is
you can say nullable enable a directive
and then it turns it on in your in your
code but you can also turn it on for the
whole project and I think that's I think
and that enable is not the only option
and this is something that I haven't
looked at in detail but you can put that
in the project file instead but there's
an able there's warnings there's all
kinds of different interactive aspects
of how this feature is going to be
enabled because it's kind of different
there are various ways in which null
ability is or nullable reference types
are different to other new c-sharp
features it's not really an on or off
thing yeah sorry the the little
conversation that's going on here that
the tag name in msbuild has changed kind
of recently so no one has it in muscle
memory yet Ram I don't have it in any
form of memory so there's an able
there's various other things and the
reason this is weird is it depends on
what the code you're calling is going to
be doing and whether that knows about
null ability and it depends on you know
what's calling you and there are lots of
different options because this is part
of an evolving
language you know if you come along to
my version talk tomorrow you'll hear a
lot more about it's really hard to plan
for change and work out what counts as
breaking on what doesn't and and how we
should evolve things but that's been I
assume one of the tricky things in terms
of design yeah one probably this feature
is it so I said I turned the feature on
you now see I have a warning in my code
I wouldn't otherwise have which says
that this constructor is not
initializing all the none nullable
fields of this class well up until very
recently there were known unknowable
fields in this class because that
doesn't didn't make any sense so I'm
essentially making the language stricter
and when you do that you kind of have to
give people a chance to ease into that
so it's not just about evolved an
evolving language it's also about
evolving source code and and getting to
this on your own time rather than being
HIV saying okay by now from now on
you're forced to do this so there's one
big switch and once you turn it on
you're you're lost in a sea of warnings
until you clean it all up and it really
is a see I mean don't be fooled by the
fact that mothers turn this on for the
one file and there's one warning I
decided I made a mistake in turning it
on in all my no design projects other
than the two I had already done this
week and they were like a thousand or
two thousand warnings and that's just
really you don't feel you're making any
progress so I didn't then did a whole
project at a time which were still faced
with a lot of warnings and it can be
quite dispiriting so my experience of
these warnings is you're playing
whack-a-mole with them so you fix a
warning and that gives you two more
warnings let's try that
so don't if you get that experience as
well don't think you're doing anything
wrong okay so so we let's do the wacom
yeah and so the the first half of the
future really is that when once you turn
this on reference types become nun
nullable you're no longer allowed or
supposed to have null in there and when
you do we get a warning so oops and and
it's being a little sneaky because i'm
not assigning notes or anything anywhere
but now because i these strings here are
all reference types and so they're now
not supposed to be not any longer and
because i am so i mean i am initializing
two of them here so that's fine but the
third one i'm leaving as null which is
the default value that again
and so I get a complaint about that you
should a sign you should initialize none
knowable properties so let's initialize
the uncle property we were saying middle
name how would you say it's equal to no
and now we initialized it and now the
one it goes away but I get another one
whack yeah that was one mole you can't
assign null to it either what are we
gonna do now
so so at this point you need to think
and this is one of the scary bits about
knowable reference types is a feature
that makes you think do not be scared of
this but be ready for it yeah the point
is I don't want it to be none novel I
want to be able to express that people
don't have middle names and the compiler
cannot possibly know that yeah I
you could write a rosin analyzer that
says fix all my no ability warnings for
me however you see fit okay and goodness
knows in this case it's feasible that a
smart analyzer could decide oh well
you're not passing things in I will make
it comply with everything you're
currently doing but that's kind of
guesswork that really is thinking about
your domain in this case we want the
middle name to maybe be null yeah oh but
I wouldn't trust any tool that assumed
that for me so this is where the new
syntax comes in this is where we are now
allowing you to say explicitly this is
where you explicit about your intent and
right actually you know middle names can
be null so there's put a question mark
on the reference type and say this is
nullable string okay and this is the new
syntactically new thing here but oh yeah
this is not so this looks really
familiar with if you've been asked what
syntax should be used for an honorable
type a noble reference type you might
well have guessed that right and you
might think that's fine that just means
it's equivalent to nullable string not
at all okay this is a different kind of
null ability and you need to think about
types in a different kind of way and
that's one of the difficult things about
the feature this is not a simple feature
but it's a fantastic feature we chose
syntactically to use the analogy to
nullable value types so question mark
means inaudible lack of question mark
means not an oval but what that actually
means one level down is different right
for value types they don't have
value types don't already have a null in
them so for them it you really get a
different type at runtime that has an
extra boolean neck its struct it has an
extra boolean next to the the nested
value but says whether it's null and on
and we can't do that but we could do
that here but then we'd be binary
breaking the whole world right so we
probably know a good thing so we don't
want to change what it looks like at
runtime so instead we have a compile
time illusion like an erase type a thing
that I was gonna map and say exactly
that thing I don't know if you were Java
developers or have been Java developers
in the past okay a few so you know how
Java generics aren't kind of real
there's this whole type of Asia thing
and you can't tell the difference at
execution time do you know who was at
least partially responsible for that
yeah so so none of all types being sort
of a compile time only thing not so
surprising really and it's a little bit
like we already have outs it's all about
they're all about the blame game we
already have something like that with
value tuples
so c-sharp tuples from c sharp 7 where
you can give them different element
names and things but that only exists at
compile time as well and the compiler
can help you with it but you need to
understand the difference between what's
going on at compile time and what's
going on execution time you'll you
probably ought to be more familiar with
that now than five years ago right and
we could have made other choices if we
were starting from scratch with if we
were building c-sharp today but here we
feel like for this feature to be useful
you know there are some choices that we
have to make design wise and and one of
the choices is that it has to be it has
to be binary compatible and has to be
runtime compatible with whatever code
you had before it has to be that you can
just turn on the feature and then you
can add null ability annotations in the
right places and get the what's the
benefit you say well that's that's sort
of what we're getting to now if we go
back to the program now the benefit is
that you will get all the pile time
calling out of where you probably have a
have a null bug right those places that
would lead to those unpredictable null
reference exceptions before you will
get them called out in your code right
so now get a warning here where I'm
dereferencing something that might be
null it's because I marked the middle
name as nullable and and because the
compiler doesn't have reason to believe
that it's not null right sometimes
you'll get a warning where you didn't
have any bugs before it's just you
couldn't really the compiler can't tell
that you didn't have any bugs right or
your code might be correct but it's
probably shady right yeah so and and and
maybe you know error-prone and you know
in the future refactoring so it's good -
it's good to heat these warnings and so
it is telling me indeed that you're
possibly dereferencing in our reference
so what can you do about that well we
could check whether middle name is null
and you not printed at all we could say
can just check if pede middle name is
null do something else you know write
your shorter version of the right line
that just doesn't talk about middle
names like that
oh the desire to run and put braces in
that I'm sorry
it's fine so that doesn't take the
warning away but if you put on else here
then the warning goes away okay so that
so the idea being that the compiler now
has reason to believe that middle name
is not null here because it's in an else
branch of something that checked whether
it was no so so that's another sort of
concession to c-sharp being an existing
language there are ways that you can
check for null that are sort of correct
by construction using pattern matching
for instance which we can do in a little
bit if you want yep but that's not how
people usually check for null they'd ask
up here is this variable null and then
or is this field null and then a little
later they use the field assuming it
wasn't since the test right and that's
exactly what's going on here so so in
order for the compiler to to appreciate
and recognize that it has to do a flow
analysis from oh you checked up here we
use the result of that check down here
to give you a pass on okay we
we get what you're doing and it can be a
little more subtle than you might think
because for one thing I tend to think of
this as a little bit like definite
assignment so I can't write int I and
then console dot write line I mm-hmm
okay that's that's invalid because it's
not definitely assigned and the the
compiler already does flow analysis for
local variables saying okay I can see
that you know maybe it branched and each
branch assigning something so then it's
definitely assigned but what's going on
here is much more than that partly
because it's not just for variables okay
it's not that we're checking whether P
is null and remembering that that
variable is null we're saying when we
invoked a method okay it's a property
but effectively we're calling a method
called get underscore middle name that
returned not null we'll assume it stays
that way
because that's the pragmatic way of
going and it can be really hard to
reason about because it's not even
guaranteed from the type you can you
could have a non nullable thing that
you're getting from you get from some
method and the compiler may not be sure
about that for whatever reason more
weirdly still you can say I'm gonna have
a nullable variable called X and I'll
assign it a non null value and do you
expect when I complete this that there
should be a warning okay I'll give it
away I originally expected it to be a
warning because I'm dotting into
something that is not able but the
compilers worked out up but the value
you're assigning is non-noble so it's
not just the type of the variable and
it's not just variables and we need to
get used to it may be hard to predict
for a while when it's going to warn us
I've certainly found that and obviously
things will be changing at the moment
while we're still in preview but yeah
but this I think this is pretty solid
it's going to be like this and again
here's this so it's if we had just
checked in all ability of a local
variable or tracked that yep that would
be one thing and that's
is safe but this is actually a little
unsafe that the compiler that you do
that it kind of shows that there are
holes in our analysis it doesn't
guarantee you that you won't get your no
reference exceptions it just gives you a
pretty high probability because actually
you know maybe me calling first name
here after the test actually mutated the
object and turned it into a nullable
maiden middle name no oh maybe it's just
so what when I give c-sharp eight demos
on my own I almost entirely show caller
cases where we can break the compiler
because that's what I kind of like and I
tend to give a property that if date
time UTC now dot seconds less than 30
return null otherwise return greater
than null sorry return some perfects and
then you know sometimes it'll see a non
null value and then go okay I'm fine and
then gets a null one and go bang
sometimes it'll get a null thing and
then not even ask the second time when
it would have got none no but basically
we assume or the c-sharp compiler is
assuming that people are writing
sensible code yes unless not always
couldn't be that often at youth yeah so
yeah so the I so the idea here so this
is just to show that there's lots and
lots of code out there already that is
null safe by you know checking a
property and then using that property
alright and that's I mean that's a super
common pattern and if we were to warn on
that because ooh somebody might another
thread might or you know some superiors
ill implement a property might have
changed and we're not doing you a favor
we're calling out all kinds of false
positives in a sense that technically
they might be unsafe in corner cases but
in practice they're not so so the
feature is very much shaped by what's
already there what's already common and
trying to give the right trade-off
between having lots of safety against
nulls but at the same time recognizing
most of you and all safe code as s null
safe yeah it's a different kind the
thing I think that it's important to
understand is this is a different kind
of type safety it's not sort of I
guarantee I will not let bad stuff
happen it's kind of
looks good to me and that takes a little
while to get into that new mental model
and hopefully we'll talk a bit later on
about new mental models that the c-sharp
team want us to all learn it does
straight me remember when we talked in
Copenhagen and talked for like three
hours or something yes we only have one
hour and he'll and it's yes and it's 22
minutes passed already and we weren't
going to spend long and though we should
probably move on that's what I yeah I've
been trying to lead up to it for a
couple of minutes but think so we do
have a nice little conditional in here
right and so that's a good I think
that's a good opportunity for talking
about patterns and switch expressions
let's yeah okay so another another
conditional construct in c-sharp is the
switch statement it's probably half a
century old syntactically it looks
aerated from language to language java
copied it from c++ perpetuated it from
seed you ever copied it from c++ we
copied it from c++ and I was by the
diagram yesterday that showed c-sharp
coming from Java C++ and Pascal was it I
remember the the Delphi the Delfy
I remember the document that sort of
introduced eShop before there was a
c-sharp one spec that said that c-sharp
was the product of VB and C++ never
mentioned Java in the entire thing it's
like everyone in the industry going
you're doing Java right you're really
doing job anyway so we could do instead
of this if else we could do it as a
switch expression if we wanted or a
switch statement if you wanted to yeah
but it's also a good opportunity to show
the switch expressions which is say
syntactic syntactically slightly less
heavyweight construct which is you know
you take an expression you switch on it
you have various other expressions as
the possible output depending on weather
patterns match and the one that wins
besides what's the result of the whole
expression so that's the sort of
language way of saying it from the human
way of saying it would you like to feel
smarter yeah would you like to feel like
F sharp and function
programmers yeah switch xpressions are a
way to get that I found that with
expression body members in c-sharp six
it's like I can now feel like I'm five
IQ points smarter and switch expressions
just do that for me again right so we
could do something like string output
equals we could switch well to if we
want an easy incrementally into this we
could switch on P dot middle name right
and week so we could say P dot middle
name switch well it's more something
switch and then give a couple of cases
here and the way you give cases in
preview the last time this happened to
me I actually had to kill and restart
visual studio I am so sorry guys so well
well that's going we can describe I can
describe what's going forever will be so
in a normal switch statement it's switch
and then the value and then open brace
and a load of case labels so you have
case foo and then colon and maybe some
code or maybe multiple case labels will
get my feature requests term ads in a
minute and within each case label there
are a bunch of statements and then
usually break unless you're returning
from the method there the and you have a
default potentially for if you don't
what you want to do if none of them
match and before c-sharp six do I mean
six or seven when did we introduce
person matching when did you introduce
about seven seven okay so before seven
the order didn't matter in most cases
because only one case could be matched
anyway so c-sharp seven-inch use pattern
matching in switch statements as well as
in is expressions and so you could have
patterns so you could say yeah I will
match an object o when it's an integer n
and introduce a guard clause saying when
n is greater than 5 and good stuff like
that so
we we ended up having a pattern as the
case label instead of just a constant
and every constant is a pattern in
itself so now having all those cases and
things whoa
ended up being getting worse and worse
we may need to plug in my laptop after
all which doesn't have the code on it
has different than okayed we may need to
is someone taking a screenshot via so
what we're gonna have instead we don't
want to have case label zero every
everything in a switch expression is
going to be a case so why would we
bother having a key word saying it and
instead of being this weird block that
contains other things that don't have to
have their own blocks which introduces
unfortunate scoping rules a switch
expression is expression switch and then
a list of cases a comma separated list
of cases so usually when you're
converting a switch statement to a
switch expression you switch round the
switch keyword and the value and you can
get rid of any brackets around the value
and then remove case from everywhere and
instead of case then the case thing
itself :
instead of that : we have a fat arrow a
goes to because it's the idea that you
know this input produces this output
this input produces that's output and
there comma-separated instead of
semicolon so you usually replace every
break with a comma you can get rid of if
you if you were returning you know my
most common thing is I've got a method
that is trying to get a value of
something and it's going to return in
every case and you can get rid of the
return statements just as you could in
lambda expressions and the final thing
is that there is no default keyword for
switch expressions instead we've already
got a pattern that matches everything
and by the time we're there usually we
don't care about what the value is so we
just use an underscore which is a
special sort of I don't know whether it
counts as a contextual keyword crew
I got my Curly's but it just means we we
discovered what I was in there okay so
no fat error so I'm really glad that you
joined this talk okay now I can show
what John just carefully took a lot of
time right to explain so now I can then
return a given a given string let me if
I have another paste area somewhere it
probably it won't go wrong my friend
okay if I paste up here and I can steal
that string out the string out of there
and hopefully paste it in there we go no
oh no I don't think we're showing this
which expression okay
what's that oh that's okay we'll
probably move on yeah but the pattern
match yeah oh but the path match it
worked the other day I might enter it
I'm and the internal preview I shouldn't
have I should find type it instead of
you is it more likely to work maybe I
don't you just want that to work I'm
yeah I I don't have the latest fiasco
yeah nice though okay we're gonna give
up on on showing now what's going to
happen is I'm gonna get a million yep
great so I can say that here's one I
prepared earlier as it were if you go to
the notice home github repository which
is predictably github.com slash no two
time slash no two time and look at the
commits from the last couple of weeks
one of them is switch expressions and I
think I've helpfully said yo you switch
expressions from C sharp ape and the
good thing about that is not only do you
get to see it without crashing anything
but you also get to see that this is
actually genuinely useful and I've got a
bunch of commits for notice I'm
implementing nullable reference types
you may notice that CI is broken
I'm at the moment on a player because
that there only has preview one a Visual
Studio 2019 and I now need preview - I'm
expecting that sort of sort itself out
in a week or so but Travis is working so
yay but you get to see all the good
things about it you also get to see that
the commits that's currently on there
that I'll be pushing on the train this
afternoon is docker FEX doesn't like
switch expressions at the moment and
just it looks like it stops parsing when
it finds one so I've got a commit that
just moves a method that's composed of a
switch expression from the top of a file
to the bottom of a file so that all the
public members between I can actually
see at least gets most of the way this
is yeah this is a very temporary hack it
will also mention the the feature
request that I have from ads so one of
the nice things you can do in switch
statements is you can say case 1 and
case 2 and case 5 all go to the same
thing now if you have a list of patterns
you can do one goes to compute value two
goes to compute value 5 goes to compute
value but there's no current way or at
least there wasn't last time I asked
about it to say gerrae I want a pattern
that matches any of these things there
is a github feature request for it that
has had some traction what's the current
thinking are we likely to get it in 8
doing there why turi having multiple
patterns that are sort of odd together
so that I can say if the monkey olive is
them is this this or this then the
answer is that is not currently going in
okay I think there's some debate as to
whether it's a good idea so that's a
promise for 8.1 yeah
so now I'm gonna do it again but I'm
going to do it with mt no okay yes yes
who came back no nope Oh oh my god
maybe it's ya cuz it oh yeah let's let's
just okay we will all run from here
we're not gonna do the with that part we
can move on to code that won't compile
ironically next in my little agenda here
is target Titan you yes how old
confident are we that when writing code
that we don't even expect to compile it
won't just crash Visual Studio well that
could be surprisingly that could be that
could be much better yep
so expect for the red squigglies in this
bit are intentional yep Oh could be yeah
okay alright so one thing that is you
know that that's annoying that's
repetition is I'm having in my array
here I'm having to say new person all
the time person that's a short type name
but sometimes you have generic types or
things that are you know it's you and
you just said you know you're declaring
a field of type I dictionary of
something to something else and now you
have two equals dictionary oh now equals
new blah that whole type once again so a
nice little feature that's mostly just
the convenience is allowing you and I'm
really scared about typing anything in
here but allowing you when the context
is given which is isn't right now but it
could be allowing you in the context is
given to to simply say a new without the
type okay just give the constructor
argument and then whatever that is
assigned to with the context the type
target if you will gets to decide what
your newing up so you could pass that to
a method that expects parameter of type
person or you know assign it to a field
that has that type so that's something
that's which nerd perspective I find
this kind of thing quite scary because
this is introducing another kind of
expression that has no type so we
already have a few of these like the
little does not have a type it's sort of
well do different things depending on
how you're trying to use it and lambda
expressions themselves don't have a type
if you have a lambda expression that
takes no parameters and and says console
dot write line whatever then you can
assign that to action but you could also
assign it to any other delegate type
with no parameters and no return value
and this is another kind of expression
as type plus expression and that raises
interesting questions when it comes to
type inference and overlay resolution it
does but most of those interesting
questions we've already had to deal with
because the write another example if you
show so we decided you know why we can
do this and not significantly complicate
the language and in many cases it's
completely given what you're doing up
it's a nice convenient so so it's going
it's going in hopefully in the next
preview and so you you demonstrated sort
of the how it's mildly useful but the
the really nice example is if you you
sort of want static var people equals
new list of person stuff and this is not
that but it's a shorter side it's sort
of if we just instead of that just do
that and Oh will I be able to do this
without any round brackets or will I
need the rail right yeah it's so you can
you can do with that okay so if you have
it an object initializer instead and
then oh and presumably it'll infer that
well I can say yes to all of them is
that running right now yeah so you still
only have to put put it in one place now
interestingly that works if I definitely
want the same concrete type yeah the
actual type on that site if it's limited
in the same way that measure is that var
is just in the opposite direction right
var can give you the interface that the
concrete type implements or something
like that I give you the most specific
type it can and presumably there's no
idea of well the default in
commentation type and not trainer mixed
features default implementation type of
I lists of T is list of T's so if I
declare it okay that's fine
because that would yeah that now we
would get complicated right this is this
is right now it's just a shorthand and
that's that's how it's gonna stay okay
but I'm going to erase this because it
doesn't compile and hopefully we will
get to actually writing something that
does compile and doesn't fresh so time
to talk about anything yeah so oh oh
we're gonna do indexes and ranges that
we forgot about those yeah that's why it
crashed okay so yeah that's right so we
have we have an array up here and so
that's a good example to demonstrate
features that are on a kill line 25
before bad stuff happens yes line 25 is
still there isn't it so line of doom
hopefully killing it isn't right what
causes the problem so we talked about
various ways that we could improve
things working with indexed things right
it's sort of vaguely inspired by the the
arrival of span into the language how
many of you have used or at least looked
at span of T which is yeah which you
know you're gonna want to know more it's
it's really it's gonna be important I
think maybe it might not be for everyone
but it's essentially an the idea of
being able to represent a chunk of
memory without sort of representing the
whole chunk of the memory right so for
instance it can be a window onto an
array but you can index it and
manipulate it through the span yeah so
an abstraction over I can get some stuff
and I can take a slice of that span yeah
and yeah good stuff so but there are
other things as well and you know a rays
are a good example of it but but there
are ways in which it's a little annoying
to work with an array for instance if I
let's say I wanted to I want to display
the last person in the array
okay so we say ray no people index now I
have to what do I do I have to say
people dot and it's an array so its
length there are length I have to
remember what the thing and well I got
intellisense mine is one okay um and
sure I can do that and I mentioned
people twice if it was a result of some
computation I would have to grab it into
a local variable so I can mention it
twice and yep you know and you could use
dot last yeah we could just link if I
the whole thing sure but it's yeah that
only works for last they won't work so
what if I wanted there the second to
last no sorry so so we haven't you you
can sort of call it a shorthand that you
can you can get you can ask from the end
instead so I can get number one from the
end gives me exactly what we saw before
so that's essentially an index that
means length minus this number and when
you say it's essentially an index the
type of that expression is index it is
in fact a new type called index so we
could say index hat one here index I
equals that and this is a new type in
dotnet core 3.0 but presumably there'll
be a new get package so that if you're
using all the versions of.net you could
bring in the nougat package in the
compiler will just say oh yeah I know
about that type I'm sure there will be
such a such a if we don't put one out
it'll be out in five seconds anyway yeah
you will
so you know so it's a first class thing
and index that knows whether it's
starting from the beginning or from the
end so you can compute with the indexes
and then apply them later
if you want to that's not always what
you want but you know sometimes you do
what's more is that you you can you can
also express ranges and so I can for
instance say that I want to go from the
the second element to the second-to-last
element in them with a range expression
like this okay
so this is really a range that also has
its own type I can say range are equals
this and arranged is two indexes it's
one for the first element of the range
and one for just beyond the last element
of the so inclusive lower bound
exclusive upper bound if you want
because in those ways the way it means
it's slightly confusing because if you
take people hat one that gets you the
last one
whereas people one dot hat one doesn't
include the last one so you need to
remember that it's exclusive which most
things already are you know if you're
using substring for example substring 0
comma 5 doesn't give you that character
with index 5 it gives you the first five
characters so it's yeah we are trying to
be consistent with what's already there
but it is a little confusing that it's
exclusive at the end it it does make for
very simple math though yeah so it's
actually this is just this is the way
you slice off one at either end so we
get the three middle people and if we if
we if we run that do I do I just want to
see if there's anything dangerous in
here you know if we run right we we
don't get John and we don't get tests
but we get everyone else all right what
test is there because we we displayed
very explicitly on the line before okay
so so that that's good for manipulation
of various indexed various various
indexed collections including spans
right so one of the things you can do
with a span is you can just get a sub
span and a sub span of that and so on
you can you can check them down and
they're all like pointing to the same
the part of span is they pointing
somebody else's memories they are
applauding just right in memory so in
particular in this case we've got an
array and we're applying the index
operator sorry the indexer with a range
not index so if you hover over people
one hat one what's the type of that
where do you want me to hover
oh yeah well let's just assign that to a
local variable and see what yeah you
want to borrow it yeah so if we because
you may be wondering is that gonna
create a copy of the array and I'm
hoping it's not yeah yes very much so
who asks are you wearing there it was
and the problem with minus one is that
that's fine except for at the end right
if you if you want to express a range
that go always all the way to the end
then you end up having to say minus zero
which is the same as zero which doesn't
mean the end it means the beginning
right so so python has a math problem
and they have a that means that you have
to sort of special case the end when
you're going all the way to the end as
opposed to when you're going in spaces
from the end and and you have lots of
it's one of the annoying things when
using an otherwise nice feature in
Python is to have two special case this
going all the way to the end versus
going almost to the end and it should
also be pointed out that these two
indexes are entirely independent so you
can have you know I want to go from
three to three from the end to one from
the end yeah or even three from the end
to five exclusive four exclusive so
still getting rid of the first one and
that's not saying I'm gonna wrap around
it's just saying well I'll take oh
you're starting at this index that
happens to be from the end and you're
finishing at this end it's the index
that happens to be from the start and of
course like everything every index
operation if you apply it to a
collection where those numbers don't
make sense where they go around you get
but the range itself is still valid and
the the type of that hat 3.4 is range
which is a new type again and you can
create those range values you know by
calling new range or whatever but the
range itself does not know about people
you could apply the same range to
multiple collections and sometimes it'll
be valid and sometimes it won't
it's just you know it's a little type
and I assume they're structs actually
yes there's structure yeah so we were
looking at what the type of a hat and
and it's gonna be used by used but it's
a rate and that you might wonder hey
that can't be the most efficient thing
yeah and it isn't right like we're
actually we have to copy and create a
new array so when you apply the range
index it to an array you get a copy whoa
so don't do that and so it's what we
should do
so what you should do is you should go
through span since that right though you
could say people dot s span so that's
not creating a copy of the array it's
just creating a span that refers to the
array yes it's creating a window onto
the same old array and then when you're
licensing it when you apply the range
index it to that then you get another
span obviously but one but of course no
no copying is happening on this and the
cool thing here and already didn't have
it let's let's
so the just you so the principle here
that we've discussed it a lot because
it's not very efficient to copy part of
the array out but the reason we ended up
with this is that it's a good principle
that the that the slicing index are the
one now apply range that it returns the
same type as it's applied to so that
will also be the case for string even
though you know a span of character
would be more efficient it's that's
gonna be kind of surprising to get back
right you get a substring so so it works
be aware of this in order to use this
use it effectively on big arrays at
least right but small arrays who cares
yeah just a situation there's there's an
assumption to say I'm using small data
now therefore it doesn't matter how
inefficient it is and then later it
becomes big without anyone going over
those joins again but this span to sort
of prove that it really isn't copy here
I've now taken so we're taking a span
over people then taking a slice of that
span and then assigning a new value into
part of that span and then we're going
to display this is creating a copy of
the array so if we taken this as a local
variable earlier and it would have
caused different behavior but hopefully
if we now
my brother for you know yeah okay and
now you it's a bit small but you can see
yes amy k panic as the third entry here
so through through the span right
through into the other span into the
array that was then copied yeah so it's
all sort of this actually yes see the
result of that printing test to start
with is confusing everything even more
but yeah but yeah so the idea is there's
a sort of memory transparency I mean but
that's not where we here to talk about
sleep nope but so I do want to get
briefly to talking about async streams
as well yep and then for the last like
five minutes or so we can talk about the
future yes sir let's do the the beyond
the future future so let's see how how
do we do this let's let's create a
little method let's do a local method
that's an iterator okay to start with as
do one step at a time
I'm gonna write a method that returns an
ienumerable of person and it's a
completely trivial method let's call it
get people that just runs through the
array and and yields a night what do we
do yield new person yield new person
okay so we've got more than one yield
statement unless that's just for more a
bit more writing I'm too lazy for that
sorry so for each bar P and people yield
P okay and maybe print that we've done
it what's yield return or you'll return
so right yeah I don't know my own
language here so I I don't do much
c-sharp I'm sorry
so so we have a method here that gets
the people and then if let's remove some
of this index range stuff because it
confuses me a little then we can say for
each bar person in get people print them
out okay so nothing new here it's just
an iterator however what if I wanted to
let's say we're emulating some service
where things are coming down over time
pretty much anything over a network it's
as the people are signing up for my
service I get I get there the person
objects I would really want to await
tasks but delay of some time let's say
500 milliseconds okay you know I want to
do something async now of course I can
to wait because it's not an async method
well let's make it a sink okay
now it's a sink of course you can't
return I'm numerable from an async
method but what you can return now is an
i async innumerable so you can see
that's one of the options here which is
a new interface that is the asynchronous
version of enumerable okay so all the
things that you've been able to reach
over all the time there's an async
version of that I wonder what we could
do with that one mmm so let's just just
to be nice let's call it get people
async because I think we probably want
to have the right and suffix there so
now the errors have gone away so
apparently I have a valid a sink method
here to a first approximation at least
but now first of all there's nothing
called get people but I'm gonna get a
different error saying I can't for reach
over is inaudible it's not an
ienumerable
fact it doesn't contain gets enumerate
so we already have yes that's an e
things but I can a wait for each it if
we make it a stuffing with it anything
yeah yeah so now so I'm fine to await it
but I have to make I have to make the
the main method an async method but
luckily you know there's a there's even
a refactoring for it I think ooh
does it tell the project oh you'll
probably make method ASIC already and
now SFC chef 72
it was seven one main message can be
async and so now that all works out so
essentially we have an async version of
streams that can represent stuff that
comes over the wire to you or gets
computed over time or whatever so
real-time streams and you can and we
have lime support for producing them out
of iterators that are async and language
support for consuming them with a weight
for each now this is not the same I a
sink enumerable as we're familiar with
from our X is it or is it now it is
essentially the same in the sense that
our X or I X rather the interactive
frame is essentially the same so now
does that mean that my libraries that
are currently returned it means that we
have we have changed the interface a
little bit over what they had right but
but I X which is a community library
that provides link over asynchronous
streams is actually going to adjust to
our we're putting the interface in as a
core interface and they're going to
adjust it so that it works but I mean if
you have libraries that currently return
the i-x one you'll need to work out what
to do next
yeah which will be interesting so I'm in
that position myself and then can blog
about it and so that's a thing streams
and that sort of completes the async
picture in it also and the async picture
at large is the subject of a talk
tomorrow that I'm going to plug which
Bill Wagner is is giving so if you want
to be reminded of all the goodness of
async and all the things to be worried
about including async streams as I'm
standing go to that talk tomorrow
and as well as async so as well as a
weight for each there'll be a sink using
so that you can asynchronously dispose
of things and be at weight using yes so
there's an ia sink disposable as well
and you can await using an ia sink
disposable but we were in bullets for
showing that now because we're because
we're running desperately short of time
desperately and desperately little short
so that's essentially what we were able
to show which was a little less than I
had hoped for
there are things that beyond the things
that don't work properly in the preview
there are things that aren't there yet
at all we showed one of them just by
mother typing but the other one that is
it's a major feature is the default
interface members which will be in one
of the next previews and the idea here
is that this is something that we
squinted a little at Java here I have to
admit you know occasionally that happens
and when you're assigning a new language
20 years ago you squint a little at Java
so they this is essentially to address a
problem with interfaces which is you can
never evolve your interfaces because
they're a public contract that that not
only has consumers but also producers
right there implementers of the
interface and if you add a new member to
your interface you've just broken all
the implementers and default interface
members are primarily there to to
address that scenario so the idea is you
can add a new member to an interface as
long as you provide a default
implementation for it so that all the
existing implementers aren't broken they
just get that default implementation for
free yep it just continues to work the
same way and so an example here is I'm
adding I have an existing implementer of
my ilogger interface I add another
overload of the log method and as long
as I implement it right there in the
interface with a so that's a method body
in an interface if some people find
offensive but you know it's it's what
the feature is about it's necessary for
the feature to work I'm sorry but so you
the console logger will continue to work
and if people use it through the
interface they can now call the new
overlord of log only through the
interface so my understanding is this is
effectively explicitly implemented it
gives you an explicit implementation
which means it's not available on the
console logger itself it's not part it
doesn't change it's public and that
would be very breaking right because
that could change over low resolution
and everything when you use it right so
it doesn't become visible on the console
logger but if you use it through the
interface now it instead of being broken
it actually but if you later on someone
thinks hey I can do a more efficient
implementation yes then you can just add
it
it implements the interface method and
always well presumably you are in
trouble if you've got a public int log
exception X then you know people are
only going to see one version via the
interface they'll only see the other
version via the class and we just have
to live with that that's all you can
already get into that today yeah and
it's not a new problem
so and it's but essentially if you if
you choose to implement the interface
method yourself there's nothing
different about it it's like today it's
just that if you don't then it gets
implemented for you so this becomes a
little bit more like an abstract class
but you still can't introduce fields but
I suspect certainly it would it would
mean that a little a lot of the places I
use abstract classes at the moment so
that I can add stuff later on I would be
able to use interfaces at least I would
if I were only targeting dotnet cause
because my understanding is yes this
requires runtime support this is only
going to well done at core or the course
a liar and Sam rain or montemagno stay
ok right yet oh so this requires new
runtime support which is actually an
first in like a decade since essentially
since generics we haven't added language
features that require a new runtime
support even on dynamic which kind of
blows my mind that dynamic can be
implemented entirely within framework et
might have been better if we did though
but it's so this is this means that this
doesn't work is this doesn't down target
and particularly doesn't target the
framework currently there's a CL are the
classic CLR on desktop doesn't support
this there is a discussion around
whether that's should be in standard to
one or not yeah so so it's interesting
like it's giving us and we're using this
as a bit of a you know canary in a
coalmine for what does it mean for us to
start doing runtime changes again and
doing them only and some of the stats
like that well how does that all work
out this is sort of our our first foray
into that and but and it means that we
if this goes well we will be open to
doing more features that are implemented
in the runtime and evolving the runtime
along with the language which you know
if we've done that all along many things
would probably have been better
so but equally would have had a worse
backward compatibility story in some
cases and yeah there are there are trade
offs yeah life is ham and that's one of
the reasons why we can now do it because
duck neck core has a better story for
sticking with the older versions you
know so yep can can the implementation
down here in telemetry logger be
explicit yes of course yes it if you you
know it you can do all the same things
as if it didn't have its its default
implementation and if I wanted to call
the default implementation from another
application 30 seconds okay so I just
want to quickly mention though you have
more things on my slides quickly wanna
mention some things that we are thinking
about for the further future maybe
c-sharp 9 one is some notion of Records
which by which I mean a drastically
abbreviated way of creating classes for
for representing data okay so it might
be that they have a syntax something
like this and you know what that would
really mean is that you you get a
constructor and a Deconstructor and and
value-based equality and and hash codes
and you know that all that stuff
properties so a it's sort of a way of
very concisely describing data which you
know functional languages are good at
this things are more verbose in an
updating language and that's sometimes
you know okay I know exactly what my
data looks like what I'm gonna spend the
next day and a half just writing the
class declaration maybe you could do
that maybe you could turn that into a
half an hour so we're looking at that
and in connection with that maybe also
looking at discriminated Union syntax
where you can describe a group of
related types in in a very concise way
which when you combine with opossum
matching is then kind of more
interesting and a lot of these features
all build and work together I I can't
wait for this I have been waiting since
c-sharp six or whatever and but I far
rather have it right than early right
and there's some ways in which it is a
little hard
one thing we would like to capture is
that it doesn't necessarily have to be
ordered it doesn't necessarily have to
be that you give things in a certain
order and and there you can they always
deconstruct it by by that order maybe
maybe you want to just describe your
records as having these name entities
and maybe you want to be able to create
them using object initializers even
though object initializes today require
you to mutate and an already existing
object maybe we can make it either with
or without runtime help make it so that
you can use an object initializer even
to engine to initialize immutable
objects right after all is part of the
constructor syntax wouldn't it be nice
if it could actually help construct the
object and so something like that and
maybe even for immutable objects having
a feature for non-destructive update as
people call it where you can create
another object just like the first one
except with these things changed so for
instance I could create John Galloway by
taking John ski and just changing is
creating a version of him that has a
different last and this does not change
my name importantly and they're still a
John skeet so that's so that's the nice
thing is that we would still have you
all nice for me anyway so so that's that
stuff that we are actively researching
now for a future version of a C sharp
and then there's more crazy stuff but
are we over time so I think yeah so in
in summary if you want to know about C
sharp 9 and get ahead of the curve learn
F sharp now it's that's true for this
stuff that when a what I don't get won't
get to is it's a little more right it's
different yeah and and there's no there
is no disrespect meant in saying that
the C sharp team is borrowing from a
sharp heavily this is fantastic for all
of us it's a really really good approach
that seems to have been working very
well taking things slowly so that we
make sure that everything is still feels
like C sharp just feels like C sharp
with a little bit more of an option a
functional bent as it were and it's it's
fantastic I don't want to be a revolt I
want to be clear that the the boring
goes both ways like right yeah okay you
have to remember to remember names now
and nullable in in F sharp Malibu is
going in there and so on so we kind of
Co evolving and that feels good
yep cool alright thanks thanks